CBS News legal analyst Ricky cleeman
joins us now Ricky let's talk about this
because it's fascinating to me I'm
curious about what you make of the case
on air you have Fox hose saying one
thing behind the scenes are saying
something very differently
what you have is this very high bar that
has to be made when there is a
defamation case so what the plaintiffs
are saying is that fox was looking for
money Fox was looking for viewers and
that's why they did what they did and
they did it knowingly that and it was
false on the other hand what fox is
saying is they're saying it really
wasn't the corporation that was doing
this and what was happening was that
there may have been some quote-unquote
commentators who were simply voicing an
opinion now opinion may be protected
under the First Amendment Amendment not
that it was simply spouting fact let me
give you an easy example if you say John
Doe won the election that is fact if you
say John Doe was the greatest president
ever seen that is opinion so what do
what fox is saying is Dominion is
exaggerating and that you have to look
at everything in context and that they
were only presenting allegations and if
it's allegations you're allowed to
present them or else we would never have
news coverage
okay that may be the legal argument but
Ricky these these Fox commentators have
a lot of power With Their audience so
they're knowingly saying things that
they know are not true according to
their text amongst themselves doesn't
that matter
well of course it matters and it's going
to matter a great deal in terms of proof
when this trial goes forward in April
that what you are saying privately and
it's exactly the opposite of what you
are saying publicly so that's why
Dominion has a strong case can it meet
that actual High bar of defamation of
showing that the information was false
that they knew it was false that they
did it anyway and that the executives
could have stopped it well we're going
to see what happens this spring
well a lot of us are watching thank you
very much Ricky cleeman always good to
see you